Le 6 mai 2012, François Hollande devient le 7e président de la Ve République française.
Il vient de gagner le second tour de l'élection présidentielle avec près de 52% des voix
contre le président sortant Nicolas Sarkozy.
Mais, était-il le candidat préféré des Français ?
Que se serait-il passé si on avait demandé le soir même au peuple français :
On vous laisse un dernière chance. Est-ce que vous voulez remplacer Hollande par un autre candidat,
du genre François Bayrou ?
Eh bien, des statistiques officieuses montrent que si un tel référendum avait été proposé le soir même,
alors le peuple aurait choisi de destituer Hollande au profit de Bayrou.
Et ça, c'est bizarre, non ? Le peuple français vient d'élire un président qu'il souhaiterait pourtant destituer
immédiatement au profit d'un autre candidat.
Si vous avez suivi cette série, vous ne devriez plus être surpris.
Le candidat élu par un scrutin est élu par ce scrutin. Modifiez le scrutin et l'élu sera autre.
Du coup, jusque là, on a étudié divers scrutins et on en a étudié les propriétés,
notamment en terme d'indépendance aux alternatives non pertinentes
et en terme de dilemme du vote utile.
On a vu des théorèmes anti-démocratiques qui montrent qu'aucun scrutin ne peut combiner
toutes les bonnes propriétés.
Et on a vu qu'on pouvait quand même construire un scrutin avec d'assez bonnes propriétés,
le jugement majoritaire, en notant les candidats.
Mais pour le mathématicien que je suis, tous ces scrutins ont quelque chose d'assez arbitraire.
J'ai l'impression qu'on a collé des bouts de bois pour faire une chaise.
Ça, en math, c'est moche. C'est horriblement moche.
Du coup, pour aujourd'hui, je vous propose une tout autre approche.
On va construire un scrutin naturel.
On va construire un scrutin élégant.
Et ce n'est qu'ensuite qu'on découvrira, tout émerveillés, que ce scrutin, parce qu'il est élégant,
possède de très belles propriétés.
Mais, pour commencer, il nous faut un principe fondateur.
Un principe inébranlable.
Un principe élégant.
Dans mes années de recherche en théorie des systèmes de vote,
je n'ai croisé qu'un seul tel principe.
Et l'auteur de ce principe
est devenu l'une de mes plus grandes idoles.
Le génie auquel je pense, c'est le philosophe et mathématicien
Marie Jean Antoine Nicolas de Caritat,
Marquis de Condorcet
Oui, il devait galérer à écrire son nom dans la marge à l'école.
Condorcet est l'un des mes grands héros.
Il fait partie d'une shortlist de personnalités à qui j'irais parler si j'avais une machine à remonter dans le temps,
à côté peut-être d’Archimède, Einstein et Laplace.
Condorcet était un précurseur de nombreux concepts en théorie de la démocratie et en probabilités,
deux de mes domaines préférés des mathématiques.
Il est aussi l'un des premiers à avoir philosophé sur le problème des incitatives si chères à la théorie des jeux,
et sur l'avantage d'avoir de nombreux avis peu fiables plutôt qu'un avis assez fiable,
un principe que l'on applique aujourd'hui en justice via la prise de décision par un juré plutôt que par un juge
et que les chercheurs en intelligence artificielle redécouvrent régulièrement à leur grand étonnement.
Condorcet était aussi l'auteur de nombreuses idées progressistes qui mettront des siècles à être acceptées
comme les droits des femmes et des minorités ou l'abolition de la peine de mort.
Alas, c'est suite à ses protestations contre l'utilisation abusive de la guillotine pendant la terreur
qu'il fut arrêté et emprisonné.
Condorcet mourut empoisonné 2 jours plus tard dans des circonstances encore mystérieuses.
Le mouvement démocratique qu'il aura initié aura eu raison de lui.
Dans le cadre de la théorie des systèmes de vote,
Condorcet énonça le principe fondamental qui suit :
Si un candidat est préféré par la majorité à n'importe quel autre candidat,
alors il doit être élu.
Dans le cas de l'élection de 2012, on a vu que le président Hollande n'était pas vainqueur de Condorcet
puisqu'une majorité préférait Bayrou à Hollande.
En fait, Bayrou était vainqueur de Condorcet.
En effet, en duel, il battait tout autre candidat.
Autrement dit, le 6 mai 2012, si François Bayrou avait été élu président de la République,
alors aucun référendum n'aurait pu remettre en cause son élection.
Et c'est pour ça que je trouve le principe de Condorcet absolument brillant et remarquablement naturel.
Si le but d'une élection est de suivre l'avis de la majorité, alors il n'y a pas de doute à avoir,
il faut élire le vainqueur de Condorcet.
On peut aisément lire le vainqueur de Condorcet sur un graphe appelé "graphe des duels".
Ce graphe contient les candidats avec une flèche de dominance d'un candidat A vers le candidat B
si une majorité préfère A à B.
Ainsi, dans notre cas, il y a une flèche de Bayrou à Hollande car Bayrou domine Hollande en duel.
Pourquoi Bayrou est-il vainqueur de Condorcet ?
Cela devrait vous sauter aux yeux sur ce dessin.
Toutes les flèches partent de Bayrou.
Bayrou bat donc tous les autres candidats en duel.
Comprendre et interpréter les résultats d'une élection "à la Condorcet" ne devrait pas poser de problème.
Sauf que, me demanderiez-vous, comment doit-on voter pour obtenir ce graphe des duels ?
Est-ce que, pour chaque duel, on doit annoncer notre préférence ?
Non. Fort heureusement, on peut faire beaucoup plus simple.
Pour voter dans un scrutin "à la Condorcet", il suffit de classer les candidats par ordre de préférence.
Alors, si il y a beaucoup de candidats, ça peut devenir long, fastidieux et compliqué
de classer tous les candidats.
Rassurez-vous, le scrutin de Condorcet n'exige pas des classements complets.
Dans votre vote, si vous le voulez, vous pouvez très bien dire que vous êtes indifférent
entre le Parti Anticapitaliste et la Lutte Ouvrière.
Mieux encore, si il y a un candidat dont vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
et si vous ne savez pas comment le classer vis-à-vis des autres,
vous pouvez très bien choisir de ne le comparer à personne.
Et ça, ça pourrait être particulièrement pertinent
lorsque la liste des candidats est monstrueuse,
comme quand il faut recruter des jeunes joueurs de football prometteurs,
déterminer les articles à accepter dans une conférence scientifique
ou élire la meilleure vidéo scientifique de l'année.
Le problème, c'est que chaque membre du jury n'a sans doute pas vu toutes les vidéos scientifiques de l'année.
En fait, chaque membre du jury n'en a sans doute vu qu'une infime portion.
Peut-on encore appliquer un scrutin dans ce cadre ?
Via un scrutin "à la Condorcet", la réponse est oui.
Chaque électeur se contentera alors de classer les 30 meilleures vidéos qu'il a vues
et on pourra alors reconstituer un graphe des duels entre vidéos scientifiques.
Ce cadre pose certes d'autres problèmes comme la potentielle non-unicité du vainqueur de Condorcet
ou la faible connectivité du graphe des duels.
Mais ces problèmes n'ont rien d'insurmontable
et pourraient même permettre de mieux comprendre les liens entre vidéos scientifiques.
Mais je m'égare. Revenons-en au scrutin de Condorcet.
Chaque électeur vote un classement des candidats.
À partir des bulletins de vote, on construit le graphe des duels
et on élit ensuite le vainqueur de Condorcet, qui est celui duquel toutes les flèches partent.
Et le tour est joué, non ?
En fait, quand vous y réfléchissez,
tout ceci était bien connu du marquis de Condorcet il y a plus de 2 siècles.
Pourtant, on n'a pas adopté le scrutin de Condorcet.
Mais pourquoi donc ?
Est-ce que c'est parce qu'il est trop compliqué ?
Non. Le problème du scrutin de Condorcet,
ce qui a bloqué la recherche sur les scrutins "à la Condorcet" pendant plus de 2 siècles,
c'est ce que Condorcet a appelé "le paradoxe de Condorcet".
Imaginons que 3 électeurs ont vu les vidéos de Science Étonnante, d'Albert le chat,
et de Micmaths sur les systèmes de vote
Le premier électeur préfère Science Étonnante à Albert à Micmaths,
le second préfère Albert à Micmaths à Science Étonnante
et le troisième Micmaths à Science Étonnante à Albert.
Alors, Science Étonnante bat Albert en duel grâce au support des électeurs 1 et 3,
Albert bat Micmaths grâce à ceux de 1 et 2
et Micmaths bat Science Étonnante grâce à 2 et 3.
Mais alors, on a un cycle dans le graphe des duels et aucune vidéo ne bat les 2 autres.
Il n'y a pas de vainqueur de Condorcet.
Que faire dans ce cas ?
Condorcet jeta ses bras en l'air
et 2 siècles de mathématiciens l'imitèrent.
On semblait face à un mur infranchissable.
Et puis, en février 2017,
un jeune mathématicien publia un article avec une solution pour franchir le mur infranchissable.
Bon, en fait, le jeune mathématicien en question, il n'est pas le premier à y arriver
et tout ce qu'il a fait, en gros, c'est voler des idées à gauche et à droite et les reformuler
juste comme il faut pour que Condorcet soit fier de lui.
Le gros du travail avait en fait déjà été fait,
notamment par Rémi Peyre dans une excellente série d'articles sur le site Images des Maths,
mais aussi par de nombreux autres chercheurs comme Ryan, Fisher, Laffond, Laslier, Le Breton,
Kreweras, Fishburn, Myerson, Aziz, Brandl, Brandt, Seedig et bien d'autres.
Quoi qu'il en soit, on connaît aujourd'hui une façon de franchir le mur infranchissable.
Mais, pour ce faire, va falloir utiliser un cheat code qui va peut-être pas plaire à tout le monde.
Il va nous falloir utiliser un scrutin non-déterministe, à l'instar de la lotocratie dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 3.
Ça veut dire que le dimanche soir, une fois que tous les bulletins seront collectés
et que le graphe des duels sera construit,
ce qui sera élu ne sera pas un candidat mais une loi de probabilité, une loterie sur les candidats.
Et ce n'est que le lundi matin,
une fois que l'on est sûrs que tous les bulletins de vote ont été bien comptabilisés,
que l'on tirera le candidat élu, conformément aux probabilités assignées aux différents candidats
par la loterie élue le dimanche soir.
Il reste à répondre à la question suivante :
Quelle loterie élire le dimanche soir ?
Eh bien, l'idée est de suivre à la lettre les prescriptions de Condorcet.
L'argument crucial de Condorcet était cette idée de préférence de la majorité entre différentes alternatives.
Pour étendre ces idées aux loteries,
il nous faut donc une manière de définir les préférences de la majorité entre différentes loteries,
et la définition la plus naturelle pour ce faire est sans doute la suivante :
On va dire qu'une loterie P est préférée à une loterie Q par la majorité
si, lorsque je tire un candidat X selon la loterie P et un candidat Y selon la loterie Q,
alors la majorité préfère X à Y plus souvent qu'elle ne préfère Y à X.
On peut maintenant dessiner un graphe des duels des loteries dont les nœuds sont des loteries
et avec une flèche de la loterie P à la loterie Q si, en duel, la majorité préfère la loterie P à la loterie Q.
Jusque-là, on a vraiment pris à la lettre les concepts de Condorcet
et on les a généralisés de la manière la plus naturelle qui soit aux loteries.
On a ainsi obtenu un graphe des duels des loteries
et, a priori, ce graphe il est infini et très difficile à étudier.
Pourtant, il possède une propriété fondamentale
qui est, très certainement, mon théorème préféré de toutes les mathématiques.
Le théorème en question est le suivant :
À moins qu'il n'y ait une égalité entre 2 candidats,
il existe toujours un unique vainqueur de Condorcet des loteries.
Ah, j'aimerais tellement pouvoir raconter ce théorème à Condorcet. Je suis sûr, ça le rendrait heureux !
Ce théorème est absolument remarquable. Il s'agit quasiment d'un commandement.
Sachant qu'il y a quasiment toujours un unique vainqueur de Condorcet des loteries, y'a pas le choix.
Si on croit au principe de Condorcet, il nous faut absolument élire la loterie vainqueur de Condorcet.
Eh bien, c'est ça le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé sur lequel j'ai travaillé.
C'est le scrutin qui élit la loterie vainqueur de Condorcet.
Et ça, c'est joli, c'est naturel, c'est élégant.
En fait, c'est tellement élégant et naturel, que je suis aujourd'hui persuadé
que si il y a des aliens très intelligents à l'autre bout de la galaxie,
mais vraiment intelligents, vous savez, pas comme nous,
alors c'est forcément ce scrutin de Condorcet randomisé qu'ils utilisent.
Et oui, parce qu'en plus d'être élégant et naturel,
ou peut-être,
parce qu'il est élégant et naturel,
le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé a de très bonnes propriétés.
Pour commencer, si il existe un vainqueur de Condorcet déterministe,
alors, par unicité du vainqueur de Condorcet,
le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé va élire forcément le vainqueur de Condorcet déterministe.
Or, en pratique en politique, des études empiriques et théoriques montrent que, en général,
il y a un vainqueur de Condorcet déterministe.
Du coup, le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé, en pratique,
va souvent nous donner une réponse déterministe.
Alors, vous pourrez peut-être vouloir mettre un bémol pour le cas où le vainqueur de Condorcet des loteries
n'est pas déterministe.
Il serait alors élu par une loterie.
Mais alors, je vous rappelle qu'il n'y a alors aucun principe fondamental
qui justifierait l'élection déterministe d'un candidat.
Comme les maîtres d'Albert l'ont très bien expliqué dans cette vidéo,
et comme je vous l'ai expliqué dans le premier épisode de cette série,
les vainqueurs d'un scrutin sont déterminés par ce scrutin.
Modifiez le scrutin et le vainqueur sera autre.
Du coup, plutôt que suivre l'avis arbitraire d'un scrutin déterministe,
décider par le hasard n'est pas si mal.
Et d'ailleurs, même dans le cas où le vainqueur de Condorcet n'est pas déterministe,
les candidats qui ont une probabilité non nulle d'être élus ne seront pas des candidats lambdas.
Si un candidat a réussi à avoir une probabilité non nulle d'être élu,
c'est qu'il a un soutien d'une majorité remarquable
dans le sens où il bat en duel d'autres candidats que la majorité soutient de façon remarquable.
En particulier, contrairement à la lotocratie,
le scrutin de Condorcet n'a aucune chance d'élire une alternative extrême, où, par "alternative extrême",
j'entends une alternative dont 80% de la population se dit vivement contre.
Par exemple, si dans le vote de la meilleure vidéo de l'année,
je rajoutais ma vidéo sur le scrutin "à la de Borda",
et si une très grande majorité des électeurs la détestait,
en particulier si elle perdait en duel contre n'importe quelle autre vidéo,
alors ma vidéo sur de Borda, malgré 20% d’aficionados,
aurait une probabilité nulle d'être élue.
La loterie vainqueur de Condorcet dans ce cas
consisterait à choisir uniformément aléatoirement entre les 3 autres vidéos.
Bref, à mon sens, l'argument principal pour l'utilisation du scrutin de Condorcet randomisé
c'est la légitimité de la loterie élue.
Après tout, la loterie élue par le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé
n'est autre que le vainqueur de Condorcet des loteries.
Mais il y a d'autres raisons moins philosophiques d'adopter le scrutin de Condorcet.
Contrairement aux scrutins que l'on utilise aujourd'hui,
le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé est indépendant aux alternatives non-pertinentes,
ce qui veut dire qu'un candidat n'aura jamais de remords
à s'être présenté et avoir défendu ses idées.
Mais surtout, contrairement à quasiment tous les scrutins dont on a parlé jusque-là,
à l'exception de la dictature aléatoire,
quand il existe un vainqueur de Condorcet,
le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé ferme la porte au dilemme du vote utile.
Un électeur a intérêt à voter selon ses vraies préférences.
Et ça, plus le fait que le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé
élit les vainqueurs de Condorcet déterministes lorsqu'ils existent,
ça veut dire qu'un vainqueur de Condorcet déterministe sera toujours élu
et le sera de façon parfaitement légitime
puisqu'il le sera avec les vraies préférences des électeurs.
On peut même démontrer que les scrutins qui satisfont cette propriété sont très rares.
Le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé est à peu près le seul à avoir cette jolie propriété.
Pour les détails techniques, je vous renvoie vers mon article.
Le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé a aussi d'excellentes propriétés
en terme de group-strategy-proofness,
et là encore je vous renvoie vers l'article pour en savoir plus.
Bref, vous l'aurez compris. J'ai un scrutin préféré.
Mon scrutin préféré est le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé,
et si je devais choisir dictatorialement notre système démocratique,
je n'hésiterais pas une seconde. C'est le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé que j'imposerais.
La dernière fois, on a parlé du jugement majoritaire,
le scrutin inventé par Michel Balinski et Rida Laraki, et devinez quoi ?
Rida Laraki a commenté l'épisode précédent, ce que je trouve super cool,
et ça m'a fait super plaisir en tout cas.
Il rajoute quelques précisions,
notamment le fait que le scrutin par note n'a pas été vraiment inventé par de Borda,
en fait, le scrutin "à la de Borda" consistait à classer les candidats
et à donner une note à chaque candidat qui dépendait du classement.
C'est ce qu'on avait vu très rapidement dans l'épisode 1.
On a parlé, à un moment, du scrutin "à la de Borda" sans mentionner de Borda.
Mais j'ai pas envie d'insister d'avantage sur le scrutin "à la de Borda",
parce que le scrutin "à la de Borda", il a pas beaucoup de bonnes propriétés,
notamment, il est pas indépendant aux alternatives non-pertinentes,
et il ouvre grandement la porte au dilemme du vote utile.
J'ai oublié de vous le recommander la dernière fois, du coup je le recommande aujourd'hui,
le livre de Rida Laraki et Michel Balinski sur le jugement majoritaire.
Il y a notamment tout un récapitulatif historique sur les systèmes de vote en général
et les systèmes de vote par notation en particulier.
J'ai aussi eu le plaisir d'avoir un commentaire de Election Alternative,
qui propose sur son site web de voter suivant le jugement majoritaire
pour le futur président de la République. Bon c'est pas le vote officiel, hein,
c'est pas ça qui va désigner le président de la République,
mais ça peut vous permettre de sentir ce que donne le jugement majoritaire si on l'appliquait demain.
Nicolas Mabire et Colonel Klorik se posent la question de l’applicabilité du jugement majoritaire en pratique
puisque, a fortiori, ça rendrait le décompte des votes beaucoup plus complexe
et notamment, calculer la médiane parmi, bon 5 valeurs c'est facile,
mais calculer la médiane quand on a des millions de données,
ça devient tout de suite impossible à faire à la main et il faut un ordinateur pour pouvoir faire cela.
Et du coup, on serait obligés de passer au vote électronique.
Alors, le vote électronique, c'est un sujet passionnant, notamment d'un point de vue mathématique
et il faudrait tout un épisode, voire plusieurs épisodes pour bien en parler.
Alors, pour l'instant, je suis pas du tout suffisamment bien à l'aise avec toute la théorie du vote électronique
pour pouvoir vous en parler comme ça. Ça viendra peut-être plus tard dans cette série
mais je vous garantis rien.
Ce que je peux dire maintenant et rapidement sur le vote électronique, c'est que aujourd'hui,
il faut absolument ne pas utiliser le vote électronique vendu par des entreprises.
Il faut absolument que le vote électronique soit quelque chose d'open source, de public,
et qui utilise des cryptographies publiques, bien connues, pour pouvoir sécuriser l'anonymat du vote.
Donc c'est quelque chose de très difficile à faire, il faut imaginer,
mais, aujourd'hui, il y a des algorithmes qui ont été proposés,
même des trucs disponibles en ligne comme helios, qui proposent de faire des scrutins en ligne
de façon parfaitement anonymisée et sécurisée.
Alors, ça garantit pas encore tout à fait l'anonymat et la confidentialité que garantit l'isoloir,
mais j'ai envie de dire qu'il faut peser les "pour" et les "contre" de l'isoloir,
notamment aux États-Unis, les élections ont lieu un mardi, un jour de travail,
donc, aller voter, ça peut être très compliqué.
Et, en France, le second tour de l'élection présidentielle aura lieu le week-end du 8 mai,
donc là encore, ça peut être compliqué d'aller voter si on a prévu un week-end de 3 jours.
Bref, tout ça pour dire que le vote électronique, surtout au vu des avancées très très récentes,
en matière de cryptographie, et des résultats, des théorèmes qui montrent que
certaines manipulations du vote électronique sont impossibles,
il me semble qu'il va falloir petit à petit considérer le vote électronique comme une alternative
de plus en plus crédible.
Encore une fois, il ne faut pas utiliser les votes électroniques proposées par les entreprises privées
aujourd'hui, notamment si c'est pas du open source, il faut pas le faire.
Mais, petit à petit, il y a des nouvelles technologies qui sortent
et encore une fois, c'est des trucs très très récents.
et, ouais, je pense que je finirais par faire un épisode dessus.
Autre inquiétude soulevée par le Colonel Klorik,
à savoir le fait que ces scrutins qu'on propose, le jugement majoritaire, ou Condorcet randomisé,
sont des scrutins beaucoup plus sophistiqués que les systèmes à 1 tour et à 2 tours
que les électeurs connaissent bien.
En effet, c'est un vrai problème. Il faut que le peuple, enfin, que les électeurs
soient capables de comprendre le scrutin pour qu'il puisse être appliqué.
Alors, je pense que le jugement majoritaire est vraiment pas si compliqué.
N'importe qui peut le comprendre.
Le scrutin de Condorcet de base peut être très bien compris par n'importe qui.
Condorcet randomisé, j'avoue, ça commence à être compliqué. C'est pour ça que
je sais pas si il va être vraiment applicable en pratique.
Ceci étant dit, je pense que les gens sont surtout à l'aise avec ce avec lequel ils ont l'habitude d’interagir,
donc la première étape si on veut que ces scrutins soient appliqués dans 5 ans,
je pense qu'ils seront pas appliqués pour la prochaine élection,
mais pour qu'ils soient appliqués dans 5 ans, la première étape c'est de les mettre dans notre quotidien.
Alors, ça fait plusieurs années que je me dis qu'il faut que j'écrive une application pour téléphone
où on utilise ces scrutins pour qu'on se familiarise avec ces scrutins.
Et une fois qu'on sera familiarisés avec ces scrutins qui sont pas si compliqués.
Une fois qu'on est familiarisés et qu'on voit les conséquences des votes que l'on peut faire,
Je pense que ça deviendra une évidence qu'il faut les utiliser.
Et donc tout ça, ça me donne l'occasion de ré-itérer ma suggestion aux nombreux viewers que j'ai maintenant,
Ça serait cool qu'il y ait une app qui propose ces scrutins,
non pas pour voter pour le prochain président de la République,
mais pour décider quel sera le film à voir ce soir entre amis, ou dans quel restaurant aller,
ou, que sais-je encore, le lieu ou la date d'une réunion.
Toutes ces décisions collectives peuvent être élues par scrutin,
et c'est souvent beaucoup plus efficace, beaucoup moins chronophage, de faire ça par scrutin,
voilà, c'est décidé. Ça évite à quelqu'un de prendre la responsabilité si ça se passe mal.
Ça a été décidé par scrutin, donc je pense que c'est une très bonne solution
pour prendre des décisions collectives en pratique
et si c'est une app qui le fait, c'est très facile à mettre en place.
Les gens vont l'utiliser et vont s'habituer à cela.
Et par l'utilisation, les gens vont se rendre compte que c'est beaucoup beaucoup mieux
que les scrutins à 1 tour et à 2 tours qu'on utilise aujourd'hui, donc voilà,
si vous voulez changer les élections présidentielles pour dans 5 ans,
je pense que la chose la plus efficace à faire, c'est d'écrire une app, de la proposer et de la promouvoir,
et je serai le premier à promouvoir une app, une bonne app, hein, qui propose tout ça,
surtout si, en plus, elle est open source et elle encode tous les systèmes cryptographiques
du vote électronique proposé notamment par hélios.
mathieu aurousseau fait la remarque que le cas de vote utile que j'ai présenté dans la vidéo précédente
était assez peu représentatif, en fait.
Pour qu'il y ait l'opportunité d'avoir un vote utile qui change l'issue du vote,
il faut que la médiane puisse être manipulée par au moins une personne,
qui ait intérêt à manipuler cette médiane
et c'est pas évident lorsqu'on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'électeurs
et finalement peu de notes possibles.
A priori, il y aura beaucoup de gens qui auront joué la médiane, et, à ce moment là,
personne pourra bouger la médiane.
Et en effet, en pratique, il y a peu de chances que quiconque ait le pouvoir de, en changeant son vote,
changer l'issue de l'élection.
Mais ça, cette remarque, elle s'applique aussi aux scrutins à 1 tour et à 2 tours.
Le problème du vote utile, c'est pas que 1 personne sache qu'elle changera l'issue du vote
en changeant son vote.
Le problème du vote utile, c'est qui si beaucoup de personnes changent leur vote,
se coordonnent d'une certaine manière pour modifier l'issue de l'élection,
alors ils pourront modifier l'issue de l'élection.
Et a priori, ça peut paraître débile de penser que plusieurs personnes vont pouvoir changer leur vote,
comme ça, du jour au lendemain, pour changer l'issue de l'élection,
mais en fait, il y a des gens qui sont capables d'influencer beaucoup de personnes
dans leur direction de vote, dans leur façon de voter,
notamment les homme politiques, les médias, et tout ça.
Et, par exemple, en Australie, où ils utilisent le vote alternatif,
où il y a des stratégies de vote qui peuvent être compliquées à mettre en place,
les politiciens mettent des tracts en circulation
qui incitent les électeurs à voter utile.
Par exemple, typiquement, à mettre le candidat rival au candidat favori
en dernière position dans un vote alternatif
ou, dans le cas du jugement majoritaire, ça serait lui donner un très mauvaise note.
Et ce phénomène est d'autant plus accentué par le fait que
les sondages, aujourd'hui, jouent un rôle très important dans les stratégies des votes des électeurs.
Du coup, grâce aux sondages, on sait entre qui et qui ça va se jouer,
et puis, si on fait un jugement majoritaire, on saura quelles sont les notes médianes.
Du coup, si on a un candidat favori et qu'on a un rival à ce candidat
et qu'on a attribué une note au-dessus de la note médiane à cet autre candidat,
alors il y aura un dilemme du vote utile. On pourra vouloir mettre une note au candidat rival
qui est en-dessous de sa note médiane d'après les sondages.
Bref, le dilemme du vote utile, ça reste un problème pour le jugement majoritaire.
Et Samuel Boudet souligne une autre défaillance du jugement majoritaire,
à savoir que le jugement majoritaire, il satisfait l'unanimité,
mais il ne satisfait pas la quasi-unanimité.
Je m'explique. Imaginons que l'on fasse un scrutin
où on élit le meilleur fruit entre pomme, poire et banane.
Disons que on a des électeurs qui préfèrent largement la pomme à la poire et à la banane.
Du coup, ils vont peut-être mettre 20/20 à la pomme, 11/20 à la poire et 0/20 à la banane.
Ensuite, on a d'autres électeurs qui adorent la banane, puis la pomme et la poire.
On a 100 électeurs de ce genre, disons.
Du coup, ils vont mettre 20/20 à la banane, ils vont mettre 9/20 à la pomme et 0/20 à la poire.
Et enfin, on a 1 électeur, 1 électeur au milieu de ces 200 autres électeurs,
qui, lui, est très mitigé entre les 3, pomme, poire et banane.
Et, il préfère très légèrement la poire. Du coup, il va mettre 11/20 à la poire,
10/20 à la pomme et 9/20 à la banane.
Eh bien, vous pouvez remarquer que, quelque soit le fruit, l'électeur, le dernier électeur que j'ai mentionné
est en fait l'électeur médian. C'est lui qui détermine, en fait, les notes médianes des différents fruits.
Et du coup, ça sera la poire qui remportera l'élection.
Maintenant, retirons la banane.
Là, on voit très bien que dans cette élection, en fait,
la pomme est préférée à la poire par quasiment tout le monde sauf notre dernier électeur.
Donc, si on faisait un référendum "pomme contre poire",
eh ben, on aurait un 200 contre 1 pour la pomme.
Sauf que c'est pas la pomme qui a été élue.
Donc le jugement majoritaire ne satisfait pas ce qu'on pourrait appeler la quasi-unanimité du vote.
C'est à dire que si quasiment tout le monde préfère la pomme à la poire,
C'est pas dit que la pomme gagne l'élection en jugement majoritaire.
Donc je vous conseille notamment cet article qui liste d'autres paradoxes liés au jugement majoritaire,
pour voir ses limites.
Encore une fois, le jugement majoritaire est pas parfait à mon sens.
Je pense qu'il est parfait au sens de personne,
donc il mérite pas 20/20 au classement des scrutins,
mais il est nettement mieux que les scrutins à 1 tour et à 2 tours.
Du coup, je ne m'oppose absolument pas à son application en pratique,
même si mon scrutin préféré, c'est pas le jugement majoritaire,
c'est le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé.
Hey, j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode. Y'aura un épisode hardcore jeudi
où on va rentrer un peu plus dans les détails mathématiques de ce scrutin de Condorcet randomisé,
notamment sur certains théorèmes de mon article.
Cet épisode clos aussi la partie sur les scrutins à utiliser dans nos systèmes démocratiques.
Et à partir du prochain épisode, on verra d'autres applications de la théorie des jeux
à l'analyse de nos sociétés et de la manière dont on vit ensemble.
En particulier, dans le prochain épisode,
on verra une cause majeure de la bipolarisation idéologique croissante dans nos sociétés.
Si vous avez aimé cet épisode, pensez à le liker, à le commenter, à le partager.
Pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes.
Merci aux tippeurs pour leurs dons, et j'espère que je vous verrai la prochaine fois.